Becca in Illinois Merry Christmas
Rebecca Merry Christmas to you
how can I help um we just found out that
our mother-in-law is having a problem
with her debt versus ratio income ratios
she is not leaving after she's paying
your debt she's not leaving enough money
to pay for our medications so
considering her dignity and integrity
should we advise her to stop paying
they're all personal like personal
finance companies just wanna loans that
like storefront operations or their
payday lenders ha ha ha they're not
payday lenders are close but yeah they
she said she needed money to pay for an
insurance premium so she went to a
personal finance company oh babe they
were they were so kind to loan her money
you know check up and delicious she's
okay yeah and then they charged her 79%
interest yeah they're so nice just
wonderful
79% 79% what so how much how much debt
like this does she have she has around
15,000 and how much she's on um she's so
security only that's all she has no
savings I think she has she gets about
$1,600 a month her medications are
anywhere between three and five hundred
dollars a month you know I guess I'm
just kind of ticked first of all that
she went out and got these loans but
then these wonderful companies are
complete predators and they prey on the
ignorant in the elderly and that's where
they prey on I mean nobody yeah this 80
year old person that can barely breathe
favor she's 80 okay what is your all
financial situation
we were doing I mean we're doing all
right we have a fully funded emergency
debt-free we're trying to you know we're
trying to save some money up to replace
like our 17-year old car so what is your
household income my household income is
one hundred and thirty thousand how many
kids does this lady have uh she had
three kids or she has three kids and
they all chip in five grand let's get
rid of this were the only people in the
position to do this out of the three
might my other concern is ten years ago
we reached down and paid off a personal
loan for her and we've been paying her
household income part of her household
expenses for the last 10 15 years and
now it's all on it again the worm has
turned okay the two of you have to sit
down with her in person and explain to
her if we get you out of this we're
going to manage your income from this
point forward and you're not going to
borrow a dime ever again and we're gonna
get in touch with her doctor and see if
there's no generic medications available
yeah because it could be she's double
paying or triple paying for the
medications that she doesn't have to
because it's it's the same kind of scam
so but if you're the only way you can
get involved is to take it over and make
sure it's run right she's 80 yeah yeah
we finally sat down with her last month
right before Thanksgiving and she
confessed to us she had these loans out
there we thought she was doing okay
what's she saying because yes good so I
don't want time I've seen her in tears
good I don't want to shame her but
that's a good indication that she's not
gonna do it again if she was arrogant
and titled about it she would go to it
again do you see what I'm saying yes no
that's good news so I think you guys you
make the you you know you're just
getting your stuff straightened out but
you make good money if I were in your
shoes I'm going
come alongside her but I'm gonna take
over a whole bunch of stuff and I'm
going to get some real strong verbal
promises that she's not gonna buying
anything else or do anything else ever I
thought we had that a couple years ago
yeah you probably did I did okay
but I my guess is that um she's not
arrogant and prideful my guess is she
gets scared she's by herself yes I would
agree she's somewhat feeble and she gets
put in these corners and she gets
intimidated and scared and these nice
people just show up to help her and
they're they're crumb bags is what they
are right mm-hm so but that's who she is
she's not a she she's not breaking that
promise with malice or arrogance she
gets scared okay I think and and so what
happens is you guys have to be the
buffer and so she doesn't need to be
afraid anymore she's gonna have she's
gonna have food and you're gonna take
care of the other issues because she
just she gets things get out of control
she doesn't know how to fix them and she
just doesn't want to bother you guys am
i reading her mail or not you know I
think you're right I was just frustrated
with her she'd done it again
and I don't blame you for your
frustration but I yeah I've dealt with a
lot of folks in these situations and
sometimes they're just a jerk or
sometimes they're you know they're you
know they're not completely there and
you're having to deal with a partial
mental situation but that's not what I
hear here
she's a classic case study for what
these predators feed on the next thing
is she'll get conned or she'll buy stuff
on shopping TV because she's lonely
she also fits that model
so if we care